bonsoir à tous
tout d'abord j'aimerais commencer par me
présenter très brièvement depuis que je
suis tout petit j'adore le sport et
et je fais beaucoup de sport après
l'école et le fait est que plus les
années sont passées
plus les gens autour de moi m'ont
expliqué qu'il faudrait mettre un frein
à cette entité de sport après l'école
pour pouvoir se concentrer sur les
études et j'ai fait tout l'inversé
et chaque année j'ai rajouté en quantité
de sport après l'école et maintenant
j'aimerais vous expliquer pourquoi je
pense qu'il est intéressant concilier
ces deux vies et comment je les fais
bien sûr je tiens à préciser que tout ce
que je vais dire provient de mon
expérience et que cela peut varier en
fonction de la personne ou de la
situation mais qu'en général je pense
que ça peu près ça peu à peu près
s'appliquer à tout le monde alors tout
d'abord je vais commencer par vous
expliquer pourquoi il pourrait être
intéressant de concilier les deux villes
est la première raison c'est que
beaucoup d'études scientifiques montrent
que
le sport permet de mieux vascularisé le
cerveau et donc d'améliorer la mémoire à
long terme la capacité d' analyse là et
la concentration qui sont des choses
extrêmement importantes dans le monde
des études
on le sait tous ensuite le fait de
concilier les deux vies vous oblige à
avoir un mode de vie a relativement
stricte où vous devrez par exemple faire
attention à votre alimentation ou à
votre sommeil pour améliorer votre
rendement
et je pense que le fait de concilier ces
deux vies vous permet de mieux vous
focaliser sur des objectifs très précis
et donc de pouvoir prétendre à viser
plus haut de plus quelle que soit la
discipline
vous retrouverez la célèbre phrase on
n'a rien sans rien c'est à dire que que
vous vouliez avoir une très bonne note
dans un examen important ou que vous
vouliez être sélectionné dans une très
grosse compétition
vous devrez travailler et dur et cela
vous apprend donc à travailler plus dur
est de plus il y a deux type d'imprévu
enfin j'en ai créé deux dans le cas des
études je parlerai plus d'un imprévu
externe
c'est à dire que vous pouvez vous
préparer un examen en faisant plusieurs
exercices et le jour de l'examen tombé
sur un exercice inattendus ou
déstabilisant mais dans ce cas là
l'imprévu provient de la personne qui a
écrit l'examen et non pas de vous c'est
donc un imprévu externe et je pense que
apprendra
gérer les imprévus du monde du sport de
haut niveau peut être bénéfique pour
gérer les imprévus du des études puisque
dans le sport de haut niveau il peut y
avoir des imprévus de la part des
adversaires mais il peut aussi y avoir
des imprévus provenant de vous même
c'est à dire que vous pensiez être
entièrement prêt à gérer une situation
et vous vous retrouvez incapable de
réagir face à quelque chose et lorsque
vous apprenez à réagir face à ce genre
d'imprévu qui proviennent de vous même
vous vous vous serez meilleurs pour
pouvoir gérer les imprévus provenant de
l'extérieur
ensuite un autre atout qui je pense
provient un petit peu plus du monde du
sport de haut niveau c'est qu'il y a un
très grand esprit de compétition qui
malheureusement est un peu
commence à être détruits dans les écoles
et dans les classes et je dis
malheureusement parce que je pense que
c'est un élément moteur l'esprit de
compétition vous retrouverez dans le
sport peut ensuite s'appliquer aux
études et vous permettre de vous motiver
pour pouvoir réussir ensuite le fait de
concilier ces deux disciplines vous
permet de toujours avoir envie d'aller
de l'avant
par exemple si une compétition ou en
entraînement ne se passe pas comme prévu
et que j'ai une bonne note quelque part
mon moral va remonter et en fait je me
suis rendu compte qu'il est pratiquement
impossible de ne pas réussir dans les
deux disciplines en même temps c'est à
dire que ça va tourner de semaine en
semaine voire deux mois en mois et c'est
comme s'il y avait un niveau imaginaire
auquel le moral demeure grâce aux
contrepoids entre les deux disciplines
de plus vous savez probablement que le
sport permet de produire des endorphines
qui sont des molécules qui ont des
actions bénéfiques contre l'anxiété le
stress ou même la dépression et je pense
que c'est pour ça que les sportifs de
haut niveau ont généralement une très
grande capacité à gérer leur stress
premièrement parce que le sport vous
oblige à vous concentrer sur l'effort
est donc à oublier les problèmes et les
troubles du quotidien mais aussi parce
que je pense qu'il est possible
d'apprendre à gérer son stress et c'est
là que le sport de haut niveau devient
plus intéressant par rapport aux sports
récréationnel le sport de haut niveau
étant un monde de compétition pure il
vous êtes vous serez sans arrêt sous
pression sous un certain niveau de
pression en fonction de votre niveau ou
delà du moment dans l'année et être sous
ce niveau de pression sans arrêt vous
finira par vous habituer et vous aurez
donc une meilleure capacité pour le
gérer et cela peut être extrêmement
bénéfique au niveau des études et puis
finalement comme j'ai déjà dit le fait
de conseillers de discipline vous
permettra d'avoir un niveau de morale à
peu près constant et si par exemple
je rate un contrôle et que le lendemain
je fais une très bonne paire faire
performances sportives
mon oral remontera et j'aurai à nouveau
envie de travailler pour améliorer ma
moyenne dans le monde des études et on
pourrait croire que lorsque quelqu'un
échoue dans une des deux disciplines et
qu'il réussit dans l'autre il
abandonnera entièrement l'endroit où il
a échoué pour pouvoir se concentrer
entièrement là il a réussi
mais si vous nous arrivons à prendre les
deux objectifs sous un seul et unique
objectif et j'en reparlerai il est
impossible d'abandonner une des deux
disciplines
alors maintenant que je vous ai expliqué
pourquoi je pense qu'il est intéressant
de concilier les deux disciplines je
vais à travers quelques règles vous
donner certains conseils pour pouvoir le
faire
et la première c'est définir ses
priorités
ça me paraît extrêmement important et ça
m'a beaucoup aidé et ça peut paraître
très simple au premier abord mais c'est
un peu plus complexe parce que définir
ses priorités
ça veut dire savoir dire non à quelque
chose et est par exemple sortir tard le
soir avec des amis ou alors ne pas aller
à un entraînement pour pouvoir
travailler et je me suis rendu compte
que le fait de toujours dire non dire
non dire non vous vous habituerez à le
faire et vous rendra la tâche beaucoup
plus simple lorsque vous devrez le
refaire ensuite ne jamais oublier ses
objectifs et celle là est liée à celle
d'avant c'est à dire que le fait de
garder vos objectifs en tête vous rendra
la tâche plus facile lorsque vous devrez
dire non à quelque chose de plus si il
faut prendre les deux objectifs qui
seraient le sport de réussir dans le
sport
prenez par exemple l'exemple d'un kinder
prenait le jouet qui serait réussir dans
le sport et le chocolat qui serait
réussir dans les études au lieu de les
voir de façon distincte
il faut pouvoir créer le kinder et voir
ces deux objectifs sous un seul et
unique objectif qui serait de réussir
dans le sport et dans les études en même
temps sinon ce sera quasiment impossible
de ne pas en abandonner ensuite il faut
éviter les excuses 6
enfin ce qu'il faut comprendre c'est que
ce n'est pas parce que vous entraînez
tous les jours et que vous êtes fatigués
que vous pouvez vous permettre de dire
que c'est à cause de ça que vous ne
pouvez pas travailler et donc avoir de
bonnes notes
il faut essayer de se mettre dans la
peau de quelqu'un normal de votre classe
et vous dire que vous devez travailler
autant que lui sans quoi vous tomberez
dans les excuses tous les jours et vous
finirez par abandonner une des deux
disciplines
ensuite il faut s'entourer des bonnes
personnes et cette phrase peut paraître
un peu génériques mais dans le cas du
sport individuel il est important de
s'entourer de camarades d'entraînement
pour avoir envie de s'entraîner parce
que ce n'est pas toujours le cas mais je
pense qu'il est aussi important de
s'entourer de personnes qui vivent la
même chose que vous pour guy de de
même chose que vous parce qu'il n'est
pas toujours facile d'être compris par
des gens qui ne vivent pas ou qu'ils
n'ont pas vécu
et puis dernièrement if il est important
de s'entourer de quelqu'un qui puisse
être capable de vous rappeler lorsque
vous vous écartez trop d'un des deux
objectifs et puis il prenez votre temps
si par exemple vous voulez ajouter un
sixième jour d'entraînement alors vous
en aviez déjà 5 et faites le et au bout
de deux à trois semaines si vous voyez
que vous n'arrivez pas à gérer votre
emploi du temps et bien retiré le
lorsque vous aurez déjà créé une
connexion et si vous restez y est au
bout de deux mois par exemple vous
verrez que il sera beaucoup plus simple
de le faire et la transition sera
beaucoup plus fluide et n'oubliez pas ce
que vous faites même si j'ai dit qu'il
était important de se comparer aux gens
normaux de d'une classe pour pouvoir
pour ne pas créer des excuses je pense
quand même que le fait de garder en tête
que vous faites deux choses à la fois
peut contribuer à vous motiver beaucoup
et puis finalement soyez compétitifs
partout c'est à dire qu'il ne faut pas
juste être compétitif dans une des deux
disciplines et il vaut mieux être un
petit peu moins compétitifs dans une d2
et lettres dans les 2 en même temps et
je pense vraiment que la compétition est
un élément moteur pour réussir
et puis je vais aborder trois chiffres
qui me paraissent importants
réussir à concilier ces deux ces deux
disciplines
le premier c'est 8 qui représente huit
heures de sommeil alors des études
montrent que le sommeil est important
pour améliorer vos réactions ou votre
concentration mais ce que l'on sait pas
forcément c'est que le sommeil est aussi
extrêmement important dans le sport
puisque dormir huit heures ou plus
permet de réduire considérablement les
risques de blessures il est donc
important de beaucoup dormir ensuite 15
qui représente 15 minutes dans une
journée et vous me direz que 15 minutes
dans une journée
ce n'est rien mais je peux vous assurer
que dans une dans une période
d'entraînement de charges vous vous
entraînez deux heures par jour et où
vous n'avez aucune envie de travailler
en revenant le soir
le fait d'avoir pris 15 minutes dans
votre récréation ou dans un moment de
temps libre pour pouvoir travailler ou
vous étirez vous faire quelque chose lié
à vos objectifs vous sera extrêmement
précieux pour ne pas avoir à les
utiliser
le soir même et finalement le dernier
chiffre 1
c'est un point et je pense que c'est la
différence que vous pouvez vous
permettre dans votre moyenne générale
lorsque vous ajoutez un sixième jour
d'entraînement par exemple lorsque vous
ajoutez de l'entraînement et si vous
voyez que votre moyenne générale descend
de plus d'un point
je pense qu'il vaut mieux retirer ce
jour après bien sûr cela peut varier en
fonction de la classe et de la moyenne
générale de base
et finalement j'aimerais attirer votre
attention sur le fait que je ne suis pas
en train de dire que c'est facile de
concilier les deux mais je pense que
c'est une expérience assez enrichissante
puisque ça permet d'améliorer
considérablement votre capacité
d'organisation et d'adaptation et aussi
parce que ça vous permettra de tester
vos limites non pas physique mais plutôt
psychologique émotionnel et puis je
pense qu'il ne faut pas non plus en
avoir peur puisque personne bien entendu
ne commencera par 14 heures
d'entraînement par semaine et cela se
fera progressivement
pour moi il ya vraiment trois règles
qu'il faut garder en tête pour pouvoir
réussir et c'est qu'il ne faut surtout
pas laisser un des deux objectifs de
côté ensuite il ne faut pas se fixer des
objectifs trop élevés à court terme
parce que sinon vous risquez de vous
risquez de tomber dans la désillusion
qui la troisième chose et votre vous
perdrez votre motivation est donc
finalement je pense que enfin je
conseille à tout le monde
essayez au moins de concilier les deux
disciplines
puisqu'il n'ya rien à perdre et tout à y
gagner étant donné que le plus souvent
le sport de haut niveau est bien vu dans
le supérieur et que la voir les études à
côté du sport vous permet de ne pas être
soumis à la pression à laquelle sont
soumis des deux jeunes athlètes qui
n'ont pas les études à côté et je pense
donc que c'est quelque chose est très
enrichissant et que ça pourra vous
offrir beaucoup plus de choix dans
l'avenir merci
[Applaudissements]